SPEAKER: He's just sort of part
of the musical furniture
of American culture.
It's just wallpaper.
With Kenny G's music,
what can you say?
SPEAKER 2:
How're you feeling?
Underappreciated in general.
♪ (PLAYS SAXOPHONE) ♪
I don't think there's
anything wrong with hard work...
That's a hard lick.
I just played it really well.
putting in the reps,
and then reaping
the reward of... "Hey,
I'm really good at this."
I think that's why my career
has lasted this long.
SPEAKER 3:
The fact of the matter is,
Kenny G, in the 1990s,
was one of the most well-known
musicians on this planet.
KENNY G: Somebody asked me,
"What kind of music do you do?
Is it jazz?"
I don't know.
You might think
it might be jazz.
"Well, is it pop?" I don't know.
You might think
it might be pop.
SPEAKER 3: He was having
a huge impact
on defining what jazz is.
Even though the jazz community
were looking at his music
with disdain.
These are songs from my heart.
This is the way I just hear it.
They think I've just decided
to play these kind of songs
because I knew
they would sell well.
If only I was that smart.
♪ (PLAYS SAXOPHONE) ♪
SPEAKER 4: People have
gotten married to his music,
had babies by his music.
He makes playing an instrument
really cool.
I been listening to him
since I was a baby.
At the same time, he is also
one of the most hated people
in jazz.
What the hell's not to like?
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
SPEAKER: There's something
deeply powerful
about the fact that music
has reached millions of people.
KENNY G: The fact that
what appeals to me
also appeals to other people,
that's the beautiful thing.